l'actualité de ce lundi c'est aussi le
procès en appel des attentats de charlie
hebdo de montrouge et de l'hyper cacher
et s'est ouvert devant la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris à quelques mètres
d'ailleurs de la salle d'audience du
procès de l'attentât du 14 juillet 2016
à nice la justice de notre démocratie
fait son travail mais quel est l'état de
la menace terroriste en france on va en
débattre dans ce sens public mais
d'abord je vous propose un zoom sur
l'opération sentinelle elle mobilise dix
mille soldats dont 3000 en réserve de
journalistes de la rédaction de public
sénat ont pu partager le quotidien de
certains de ses militaires c'est un
reportage signé norbert évangéliste à et
jérôme vallier
gare montparnasse un train au départ à
une heure de grande affluence
rien d'étonnant à trouver poster ici et
là ces sommes aux aguets comme inscrit
dans le décor depuis que la france fait
face à la menace terroriste vient risque
c'est ça on regarde un peu tout le monde
en garde si personne fait tomber un sac
si facile
donc on est vigilant là dessus les
soldats de l'opération sentinelle assure
la protection des points sensibles du
territoire il mène une track 100
fugitifs avec comme arme principale un
sens affûté de l'observation celui qui
me regardent méchamment dans la rue on
peut se dire qu'il n'a pas envie de nous
voir ici donc ça peut ça peut être
quelque chose de suspect
les grecs il nous invite quelqu'un qui
nous évite aussi une partie
l'opération sentinelles a été déployée
au lendemain des attentats contre
charlie et d'eau preuve que la france
n'a pas baissé la garde depuis des
décennies contre le terrorisme
sentinelle avait aussitôt succéder au
plan vigipirate déclenché lui après les
attentats du rer saint michel en 1995
depuis la france n'a cessé de monter en
puissance dans sa lutte contre la
terreur ou sentinelle c'est une
opération qui est plus étoffé qui est
plus dynamique avec
un principe de rôle de patrouille qui
est plus aléatoire que vigipirate le
maintien le maintien de cette opération
démontre bien une
présent ce sont des menaces terroristes
à vérifier une menace terroriste avéré
le ministre de l'intérieur ni allé
récemment pas par quatre chemins en la
qualifiant de particulièrement élevé et
venant d'un individu précisé t-il déjà
présents sur le sol français pour les
spécialistes rien n'a changé depuis les
attentats de saint michel
le terrorisme n'a jamais désarmé en
vérité la menace terroriste n'a jamais
baissé d'intensité ce qui a baissé c'est
la transformation de cette menace en axe
terroristes heureusement grâce
travail qui a été accompli notamment par
les services de renseignement un certain
nombre d'actes
été déjoué
mais aussi la réorganisation d'une
organisation comme des ch pour ne citer
qu'elles ah je dirais retarder ou en
tout cas fait baisser d'intensité
le niveau de la menace pour une période
donnée j'ajouterai qu'il y a toujours eu
une menace ondo j'aime une menace
intérieure qui représentait par des
personnes parfois identifier d'autres
fois non qui sont impactés par le
discours dit à dist de façon générale et
qui sont très sensibles au discours
visant à diaboliser la france des
personnes souvent des individus isolés
qu'à tout moment les soldats de
l'opération sentinelle pourrait devoir
affronter grâce à leur vigilance entre
autres en france de plus près d'un an
sur lui tentative d'attentât six ont été
déjoués
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités marc trévidic bonsoir soir si un
juge antiterroriste président de corée 6
à la cour d'appel de versailles nathalie
goulet bonsoir vous êtes sénatrice
centriste de l'orne vice président de la
commission des lois et auteur de cet
abécédaire du financement du terrorisme
qui est publié aux éditions du cherche
midi wasyl nation soir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes journaliste spécialiste
des mouvements et mouvance jihadiste à
france 24 et matthieu croissandeau est
resté à mes côtés je le disais avant de
lancer ma clique sur portage sur sur le
l'opération sentinelle en ce moment
c'est le temps des procès en france il
ya eu le premier semestre de cette année
il ya eu le procès en appel de deux
options soit de charlie hebdo montrouge
et l'hyper qu'à chaque s'est ouvert ce
matin à quelques mètres de là dans le
palais de justice ya le procès des
attentats de nice qui ce qui se déroule
voilà notre démocratie elle fonctionne
sa justice est à l'oeuvre c'est un
message important je pense qu'il faut
renvoyer son dépôt c'est qu'ils sont
importants pour les victimes mais est-ce
qu'on peut y apprendre quelque chose
c'est la question que je me posais en
disant tiens j'ai j'ai eu la chance
alors marc trévidic sur mon plateau est
ce que ça vous arrive de découvrir
quelque chose que certains des accusés
volontairement ou involontairement
finalement
vous apprennent quelque chose dans des
procès comme ça découvrir c'est un grand
mot c'est plutôt euro retomber sur terre
bien que ce sont les attentats tellement
horrible qu'on a l'impression qu'on va
avoir des monstres en face de soi
également le diable qui sort d'une boîte
et à chaque fois qu'on assiste à ces
procès et moi j'y suis allée à comme
témoin pour v13 et puis d'ailleurs je
vais y aller aussi en appel pour il
attendra de janvier 2015 eh ben on a
finalement d'aider des gens qui quittent
qui en naturel assez fade qui sont assez
assez banal finalement le crime un peu
banal même terroriste vous avez ressenti
ça aussi comme toute action les gens qui
ternit tout à fait en face de moi
j'avais des gens sauf exceptions j'ai eu
trois quatre personnes qui sortaient du
lot dans toute ma carrière mais pas
beaucoup plus le reste c'est vraiment le
basique il faut voilà et donc on est
très surpris de voir à quel point avec
l'effet de groupe avec effet de
l'idéologie des gens qui sont assez
ordinaire des petits jeunes vont pouvoir
aller dans la violence extrême dans la
barbarie dans des choses tout à fait
horrible c'est nous apprend beaucoup sur
l'espèce humaine et le danger d'une
idéologie daté ligoule et comme
parlementaire comme sénatrice qu'est ce
que vous attendez de ce temps judiciaire
le temps des procès visait notre justice
fonctionne elle le montre je crois que
c'est que vous l'avez dit c'est vraiment
très important pour les victimes je
crois que c'est déjà fondamentale et
puis aussi le fonctionnement judiciaire
qui dès qu'il est en train de s'habituer
finalement à des procès de masse de ce
jean qui sont quand même des procès
extrêmement douloureux donc nous en tant
que législateur on attend que la loi
soit bien appliquée ce qui est généré ce
qui est évidemment le cas et puis aussi
voir quels dispositifs éventuellement il
manquerait face à l'ingéniosité
de ces gens même tout à fait ordinaire
qui ont quand même commis l'irréparable
donc c'est aussi pour nous très
important de percevoir aussi la
mécanique et jeu on se demande aussi
c'est sans doute la question vous est
posée voici menace quand quand y avait
le premier semestre de cette année le le
procès de salles abdeslam des complices
des attentats du 13 novembre
est ce qu'un groupe terroriste a
aujourd'hui les moyens de mener une
action similaire mois à chaque fois que
j'avais voilà que j'assistais enfin j'ai
pas assisté que que j'avais le retour de
mes confrères sur ces audiences je
pensais à ça en fait il faut s'imaginer
que le trésor c'est vraiment
exceptionnel moi même en termes
d'attaqué ou d'attentats terroristes et
reste exceptionnellement c'est unique en
tire même organisation entendre ils sont
et de projection de force on va dire
parce que bon il ya eu le 11 septembre
mais par exemple les attaques similaires
à bruxelles les terroristes les
assaillants étaient déjà à bruxelles ils
n'ont pas été projeté donc depuis le
levant donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et ce qui a permis en
tout cas d'états islamiques de commettre
ces attaques c'est le facteur européen
le facteur humain européen donc ce sont
des djihadistes européens qui ont été se
battre là-bas s'aguerrir là bas avec
autant assez de volonté on va d pour
revenir avec les réfugiés assez de
connaissances dans le monde va des
criminels pour pouvoir acheter des armes
fabriquées l'explosif avoir des points
de chute et finalement mourir en
kamikaze et ça c'est une denrée rare
pour un groupe djihadiste est
aujourd'hui donc même si la volonté ne
manque pas on va dire que ce soit chez
l'état islamique ou chaliche al-qaïda
d'ailleurs mais ils n'ont pas cet
élément là donc le facteur humain qui
puisse projeter ils l'ont encore
peut-être qu'on en parlera dans les
prisons
donc dans le désert série 1 chez les
kurdes ya encore des européens à guérir
au combat toujours fidèle à l'état
islamique ils sont dans les prisons oui
si un jour ils sont libérés les
tahitiens il va récupérer ce facteur
mais vous alors où on ne parle l'état
islamique n'a pas ce facteur humain
européens pour pouvoir projeter une
force telle que celle du 13 novembre
est-ce qu'il peut motiver des attaques
comme on l'a vu dernièrement à vienne
par exemple ou des sympathisants états
unis qui passent à l'acte oui évidemment
mais des cellules de combattants je
pense qu'alors on parle aujourd'hui
n'ont pas cette capacité justement
encore une fois je mets d'insister là
dessus parce que c'est le facteur humain
qui prime oui alors il danse que visite
il ya deux aspects il ya le
la menace effectivement extérieur et
puis la menace intérieure on va vraiment
scinder ce débat en veut même si ça se
recoupent on l'a on l'a bien compris
pour avoir un groupe terroriste très
efficace il faut des relais à
l'intérieur des pays en question c'est
pour ça que je me méfie un peu endogènes
et exogènes ses fans vous utilisez pas
forcément cette perte alors parce que on
avait vu quand les gia algériens ont été
très puissant 95 parce qu'ils étaient un
groupe très puissant en algérie ils ont
pu s exporter mais aussi parce qu'il
avait plein de relais en france on a eu
trop vite quels cas et c'est comme si
voilà mais là c'est pareil il y aurait
jamais eu les attentats de novembre 2013
s'il n'y avait pas de 2015 pardon s'il
n'y a pas eu tous ses relais alors
évidemment à molenbeek on a bien compris
mais mais généralement ils sont partis
en syrie ils ont plein de copains qui
sont restés en faire il faut une base
arrière assure importante évidemment là
mais il faut des relais d'ailleurs quand
on en a pas qu'est ce qui se passe on se
retrouve dans un buisson et c'est ça la
fin de de damas où il finalement à pas
savoir où aller ou allez vivre et à
devoir dépendant de gens qui peuvent qui
peuvent vous dénoncez entre guillemets
donc pour avoir des gens vraiment
convaincu quand vous qui vont vous
accueillir que vos données papier des
voitures qui va vous cherchez il faut un
groupe puissant terroriste doit avoir
des relais
humains idéologique de d'infrastructures
dans le pays donc la menace est très
grande quand il ya les deux à la fois ça
veut dire qu'il ya une filière et plus
de réseaux dormants ils ont été très
très des manqué par par tout ce qu'a
fait l'europe et la france en
particulier après 2015 on a eu quand
même donc il ya quand même pas mal de
gens qui ont été arrêtés qui ont préféré
par prudence ne plus rien faire qui
aujourd'hui font canards oies canards ça
veut dire qu'ils ont comme s'il est
surtout un peu plus loin il faut plus il
faut plus mais au cas où une pâte à
aujourd'hui on a une époque incroyable
vous rappelez vous on avait des gens qui
venaient revendiquer leur salafistes
dans les rues fort analyse en france on
à sharjah for belgium charia en bois et
habitat
les abreuvant la charia chez nous
c'était déjà en belgique en
grande-bretagne ou en france qui
piétinaient le code pénal mike foreman à
la disa il revendiquait il n'avait pas
peur de nous il n'avait pas peur qu'on
leur dise ça suffit on vous expulse on
vous arrête on vous en fait une
procédure on pouvait pas aussi parce que
la loi le permettait ça c'était voilà
une vidéo c'était plus grave n'était pas
été beaucoup plus compliquée et
l'angleterre c'est encore plus vrai à
l'époque 95 brasserie damas tout ça
voilà donc aujourd'hui ils ont peur ils
savent qu'ils risquent beaucoup s'y
montrent leur intégrisme religieux même
sans utiliser la violence rien que ça et
donc tout le monde fait très attention
nathalie goulet ce qu'on a aussi
affaibli en quelque sorte cette menace
en étant plus
radical dans dans la lutte contre les
filières de financement ce sur quoi vous
avez travaillé oui alors je voudrais
compléter enfin en tous les cas mais
ceci est ce qui vient d'être dit parce
que en réalité le dispositif législatif
entre 2013 2014 2015 2016 devaient
finlande a voté aussi cette loi on a
vraiment et puis renforcé nos forces et
nos moyens et renforcer aussi les
services de renseignement et j'ajoute la
coopération internationale donc tout ça
vraiment affaibli le haut du spectre en
tous les cas des réseaux terroristes et
puis sur le plan du financement il a
aussi été mis en place un certain nombre
de dispositifs extrêmement contraignant
de façon à ce que notamment ils y ait
des rede et des systèmes de détection
précoce et puis évidemment traque fin
qui est notre renseignement financier
ainsi que la coopération internationale
sur ce sujet donc oui on a affaibli sans
compter évidemment
l'affaiblissement de dèche la fin des
trafics ou en tous les cas leur
élimination ça a commencé quand même par
part ça aussi je
vous faites allusion à la coopération
internationale moi j'ai en mémoire après
le trésor en valeur de mémoire vous me
poserez mais que salle abdeslam au kit
paris se fait contrôler à la frontière
belge il est fiché en france et ils ne
sonnent pas en haut à la frontière belge
on le laisse passer est que l inverse il
y avait des gens qui étaient connus côté
belgique mais qui était pas connu côté
français disent que ça ça a été résolu
au niveau européen ce qui est un vrai
échange d'informations antiterroristes
à la des slams il est jugé à bruxelles
depuis ce
soir il ya un malentendu quand même y'a
plein de gens fichiers ou simplement ils
sont fichés by fâche le fichier s on
veut simplement savoir où la personne se
trouve ci est pas et frontières c'est
pas un mandat d'arrêt par l'adami c'est
pas ça qui fait qu'on peut arrêter les
gens attention faut pas oublier ça non
plus on a l'impression peut afficher ça
veut dire comment ça je peux passer la
frontière oui c'est fait pour ça son
passager signaler ces lois là c'est
simplement ça ça veut pas dire qu'un
policier belge à un moment donné va
pouvoir arrêter aura un mandat pour
arrêter quelqu'un qui l'art de france
vers bling même si les fichiers connus
des services demanda ya pas de mandat
c'est aussi la loi et
on a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
amélioré alors parlé de 2013 moi je vous
parle déjà de 2014 2015 vient s'ajouter
à former on est déjà sur des sur des sur
une période un peu plus récentes avec un
coordinateur européen du renseignement
avec un certain nombre d'outils un
parquet terroriste par 40 et terroristes
etc donc je pense que j'ai des bonnes
raisons de penser que l'information
circule quand même beaucoup mieux ça
n'empêchera pas un fichier s de
traverser les frontières parce que
l'affichage comme on l'a rappelé
plusieurs fois dans cette maison est
comme vient de le faire juge c'est le
président s'est évidemment pas une
présomption de culpabilité
donc encore une fois il faut il faut
remettre les choses comme elles comme
elles sont
l'état de la menace pardon je reprends
quand même ce terme là extérieur je
propose d'entendre le théme âge de
nicolas lerner qui est directeur général
de la dg si la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure il était sur rtl
lundi dernier depuis maintenant quelques
mois nous avons un stand d'indication de
signaux faibles qui nous montre à la
fois que les intentions des groupes
terroristes restent aujourd'hui de nous
frapper de frapper l'occident de frapper
l'europe et de frapper la france très
clairement les services aujourd'hui
n'ont pas détecté ces derniers mois de
projets concrets de projets matérialiser
visant la france et a fortiori pas de
projets aujourd'hui sur lequel nous
travaillons et qui viseraient la france
ce sont des intentions et c'est dans le
même temps et vous le suivez également
la démonstration que ces groupes
terroristes sont de plus en plus en
capacité de nous frapper
voici nos crs qui a peut-être du côté de
la syrie des des groupes jihadistes qui
existait déjà ou qui sont en train de se
renforcer aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
c'est en tout cas la menace vis-à-vis de
l'occident et à vis de la france
éliminions syndicats lyncher les
jihadistes se soit d'al qaïda ou de
l'état islamique se félicitait des
attaquants français mais après encore
une fois est-ce qu'ils ont les moyens de
mener à bien ses projets donc comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure ils n'ont pas le
facteur humain mais comme vous le
rappelez aussi très bien c'est que le
fait d'avoir beaucoup de djihadiste
français et européens dans ce vide
judiciaire cette zone grise qui est le
nord-est ainsi rien pose un vrai un vrai
problème parce que je vous rappelle pas
encore janvier l'état islamique a commis
une attaque à saka contre la prison de
grasse où il y avait beaucoup
d'adolescents et de jeunes et de moins
jeunes djihadistes locaux de la région
mais aussi européens d astrid
australiens deux britanniques etc et que
des centaines se sont échappés dont au
moins trois chefs de l'état islamique et
quand on sait comment l'état islamique
fonctionnent elles étaient amies qui
existe depuis 2006 en irak on sait que
casser les prisons ça fait partie du
dogme ça fait partie des objectifs
numéro un de l'état islamique a cassé
les prisons ils l'ont fait en irak après
période calife al c'est ce qui leur a
permis de prendre la moitié de l'essai
de la série et de la moitié de garage
aujourd'hui ils le font au congo ils le
font au nigeria et rien ne les empêche
de refaire ce qu'ils ont fait à dakar en
janvier en série d'ailleurs hier ils ont
diffusé une vidéo on voyait qu'ils
avaient attrapé six membres du bp gay
donc l'oeil et pdc la cdc les milices
kurdes et arabes qui travaille avec la
coalition à la sortie d'un camp
d'entraînement dans l'est syriens ils
les ont achoppé pour dire les choses
simplement sur la route de leur village
et ils les ont tués pour venger ils ont
dit on nous les guillemets leur soeur
dans le camp à l'autre donc le camp à
l'ohl c'est aussi cette concentration de
femmes et d'enfants dans le nom scc rien
qui soit syriens irakiens des français
et d'autre et plus juste à titre
indicatif il ya 80 naissance par mois
dans ce camp-là et l'enfant qui a été
amené par ses parents dans cette région
et qui avait 10 ans en 2018 2019
aujourd'hui c'est un
préadolescent donc à même de porter les
armes et à même de vouloir venger on va
dire ses parents tués par l'écho la
coalition ista et ces jeunes là qui sont
quand même finalement français et autres
européens sont de la matière première
pour les t5 et là on parle du n'en est
rien on parle pas non plus et le juge
trévidic doit aussi savoir 7 reconnaître
cette problématique de idlib eydelie oui
encore des camps ou des français sont
présents avec femme et enfants et qui
grandissent là bas il ya des français
prisonniers d'autres dialysés et donc
c'est on est jeune et on est vraiment
dans quelque chose qui qui qui dont on
le pas aujourd'hui mais qui est vraiment
le coeur du problème vous vous posez la
question de la menace venant de lettres
de l'extérieur jeudi la menace de
l'extérieur mais avec des dialyses
européens qui sont là sous cloche mais
ma chronique c'est une question qui se
pose depuis plusieurs années c'est ces
jihadistes français est-ce qu'il fallait
mieux les avoir entre guillemets sous la
main dans les prisons françaises et donc
ne pas seulement juger moi je pense que
oui avec la rigueur nécessaire les
prisons sécurisé qu'il faut et les
peines qu'il faut derrière on s'est un
peu se mettre la tête dans le sable de
dire en laisse dans une zone très
trouble savez nous on a par moments on a
dû aller rechercher et arrêté des gens
qu'il avait déjà était peter chérif et
j'aurais fait pareil sevadec 300 ou 350
je sais pas donc des gens bien connus
d'irak dira qu'il faut appeler hilare
dans la nature et c'est à la fois à
nouveau un ennemi pour nous voilà donc
ces votes les avoir sous la main c'est
compliqué ça demande des moyens sa
demande faire des idées vraiment des
moyens pénitentiaire important
des cours d'assises qui se tâtent c'est
sûr que c'est du boulot c'est pas s'est
pas séparé en a beaucoup on est très
inquiet par ce qu'ils vont sortir de
prison de france où je comprends bien la
complexité je ne veux pas simplifié mais
franchement vu le vu la zone troublée
cette région là c'est quand même plus
sécure d avoir en plus en europe tâche a
été arrêté à djibouti comme à plusieurs
années plus tard échapper d'irak arrêté
à djibouti juste pour que vous y mettre
après un passage au yémen donc c'est des
gens bougent aussi vous dites nord-ouest
syrien gelé retenue mais aussi l'afrique
de l'ouest nathalie goulet avec des
signes quand on la prépare l'émission
olivier il faut il faut voir ce que
l'arabie saoudite fait en termes de
contrôle de surveillance des réseaux
sociaux expliquez nous ce qu'il sait de
quoi il s'agit alors il ya une à une il
ya un établissement à ryad qui
travaillent avec des moyens
qui ferait probablement bondir la cnil
qui est un contrôle des réseaux sociaux
y compris télégramme extra et là il
étudie très précis ça s'appelait nidal
et il étudie très précisément avec des
centaines de personnes qui travaillent
les avec des mots clés des messages qui
peuvent être des messages terroristes et
ils ont tout à fait indiqué travailler
sur la la translation
delà de la somme de messages liés au
terrorisme
de la zone
syrienne irakienne vers l'afrique de
l'ouest il ya une translation de cette
concentration de message à contenu
terroriste est donc cet outil qui est un
outil de détection peu à très moyen
terme voire à court terme devenir un
outil de prévention mais on ne
l'appliquent pas ça ressemble un peu à
un système israël il ya moitié pegasus
moi j'ai tout ça mais c'est un système
qui existe à ryad oui mais alors il
n'existe en arabie saoudite marque très
unique donc
que peut-on faire confiance à ce pays
pour pour nous aider dans cette lutte
antiterroriste je sais bien que la
question est trop vaste
d'abord d'abord moi je sais toujours des
réserves énormes flora by side plus que
c'est quand même eux qui ont propagé le
wahhabisme sur la planète qui exactement
comme le salafisme il n'y a pas beaucoup
de différence sauf qu'il y en a qui
utilisent la violence contre occident et
d'autres pas point donc ils sont ils ont
quand même la même idéologie radicale et
que je pense que du problème c'est
d'abord l'idéologie le radicalisme
religieux et que ceux qui les propagent
peuvent pas être vraiment nos alliés
complètement ils ont toujours des
tendances à écouter avec une oreille
attentive ceux qui ont le même discours
et la même religion la même vision de
l'islam que c'est à peu près c'est
naturel présenté comme ça bien sûr
aujourd'hui leur intérêt c'est de lutter
contre un ennemi qui les a touchés aussi
violemment il c'est quelqu'un qui a les
a atteint violemment
mais ils ont ils ont aussi des intérêts
stratégiques qui peuvent être différents
très vite des nôtres parce que c'est une
zone trou parce que eux c'est d'abord
les chiites qui combattent c'est d'abord
le l'iran et que ça sera pas toujours
offert pas toujours sur la même ligne
ils ont donc des contacts avec des
groupes djihadistes gens toujours eu
historiquement donc c'est un c'est un
ami qui peut s'avérer très dangereux
parce qu'il a il a une connaissance et
des liens dans tout dans tous les
milieux salafistes djihadistes dans tous
les groupes terroristes qui existent
sonique serait sur la planète clairement
depuis le début depuis la lutte contre
les soviétiques bah tu veux parler
d'idéologie est ce que on aimerait
maintenant on a un peu de recul est ce
que on peut d radicaliser est-ce que la
déradicalisation ça marche est ce qu'il
ya des exemples de repentis ça sent ça
c'est une question qui se pose les
centaines de
deux condamnés qu'ils sont sortis de
prison c'est un exemple de repentis vous
savez vous avez des gens célèbres pour
être lu des livres qui que ce soit de
l'époque de 95 que ce soit à l'époque
aussi des six français que tel
on a sur les murs aux yeux verts que
tékété que j'étais en prison au maroc
pour les attentats de casablanca qui a
été rapatrié en france j'ai oublié son
nom un peu importe lui aussi les zones u
catholique très très dur dans l'autre
sens toujours besoin d'un certain
extrême mais voilà
richard robert et s'appelle celui là
donc il ya quelques exemples de gens qui
étaient très rapides et d'outils voilà
mais sinon le premier est pas là c'est
que j'ai vu moi pas mal de jeunes qui te
très peu radicaliser ça peut paraître
surprenant et ça fait ça fait faire des
bonds mais j'ai vue d'aider des petits
jeunes dans la dernière phase qui avait
passé simplement une semaine voire
quinze jours en syrie pas beaucoup plus
et puis il était reparti assez vite il
était allé là par effet de mode on ne
sait pas trop pourquoi
avec un fond idéologique les rues les
maisons de disques dont on ne sait pas
très bien au fond
un ans qui préparait son coup
du sang sur les mains il ya ceux qui
n'ont pas qu il ya des gens qui ont été
dans cet effet de mode dans le fait que
l'état islamique a accueilli tout et
n'importe quoi n'importe qui alors
quelques qaïda était plus restrictif
résultat il ya des gens qui sur les lacs
dont ils sont très peu radicaliser il
arrive à jaca il allume une cigarette il
se prit un coup de bâton quoi ils ont
pas compris le fil après il faut juste
d'imaginer en deux mots que le chemin
inverse toujours très personnel ça veut
dire c'est pas une maladie c'est un show
c'est un engagement politique quand même
personne a cédé radicaliser les
communistes les nazis etc c'est un choix
politique et on peut se désengager de la
violence et faire le chemin inverse donc
il ya des exemples venant de personnes
qui ont fait le chemin inverse mais sur
une décision personnelle qui ne peut pas
être imposée par un programme propres à
une pilule rouge une pilule bleue c'est
très juste mais y associent conduit sang
sur les mains et c'est beaucoup plus dur
après encore on a tué deux êtres humains
qu'on a fait les atrocités de revenir en
arrière parce que si on fait ça on
oublie de se considérer comme un
criminel et pas comme pierrick qui a tué
pour une cause juste c'est très très dur
psychologiquement
qu'on a fait les atrocités de se dire ce
que j'ai fait n'était pas juge je suis
un criminel c'est aurait plus que j'ai
fait je vous aime la vie pourra
décelable c'est compliqué je vous donne
la parole tout de suite sur cette
question à un chiffre et une réaction
aux chiffres ces 84 détenus condamnés
pour terrorisme sortie de prison en 2021
et je vous propose d'entendre ce que dit
le procureur national anti terroriste
jean françois ricard sur ses sortants de
prison
on écoute dans une seconde jean françois
ricard
format terrorisme idéologique
et par conséquent ce serait très naïf
de croire que une hausse majorité de
ceux qui ont été condamnés pour des
actions terroristes de type jadis
aujourd'hui abandonné leur idéologie on
constate même fort souvent qu'ils n'ont
rien perdu leurs convictions at high
yield hy boulais c'est là la question on
est dans un état de droit on le rappelle
ils ont purgé leur peine qu'est ce qu'on
fait après alors ce problème de la
déradicalisation que moi j'appelle
plutôt reconstruction du lien citoyen
parce que la déradicalisation ça pas de
grand chose jusqu'à maintenant c'est
comme un fiasco absolument complet bon
que ceux ci a coûté cher c'est quand
même beau et très aussi en oui bon le
que seuls ces ip dr ou des ou des
marchands d'illusion marchant 2
d'ailleurs tu illusion sur ces sujets ça
a été quand même assez douloureux alors
je voudrais quand même souligner une
expérience pas seulement à la prison des
femmes de rennes
sur un quartier de déradicalisation qui
me semble tout à fait intéressantes
comme à la fois comme méthode à la fois
comme moyen pour pour des femmes qui
sont justement incarcéré pour ces motifs
donc je pense qu'on va probablement vers
enfin une solution mais pas mais pas
pour l'instant tous les cas cette unité
de la prison des femmes de rennes me
semble très intéressante et j'aurais
juste une demi-seconde revenir sur
l'arabie saoudite
qui en ce moment dans les institutions
chargées du financement du terrorisme
voire du blanchiment et sert à
l'arabie saoudite et mieux notés par le
gafi pour ses efforts le gafi parle que
le que le groupement qui s'occupe de
lutte contre le financement du
terrorisme et le blanchiment et mieux
notés pour ses efforts par exemple que
nos amis rien je parle pas d'autres pays
du golfe qui jouent au football donc
voilà donc là si vous voulez on a quand
même des progrès qui sont faits personne
ne dit que tout est parfait il se passe
quand même des choses parce que je crois
que le name and shame
notamment pour ces pays qui veulent
s'ouvrir a eu un effet probablement
salutaire et heureusement d'ailleurs sur
des comportements antérieurs je ne dis
pas que tout ça est parfait je dis
simplement qu'il ya quand même des
progrès tangibles qui sont faits qui
sont encore pas parfait mais en tous les
cas pour la lutte contre la
radicalisation pour venir je crois qu'on
n'a pas encore exactement la pierre
philosophale d'ailleurs pour les
premiers concernés les djihadistes en ce
qui concerne l'arabie saoudite on va
parler avec pas mal de saoudiens
jihadistes ils disaient tous on
reviendra quand conquérant pour couper
la tête des saoud ces impies donc ça il
faut aussi imaginer et si les pays du
golfe se sont engagés dans ce combat
c'est parce qu'ils savent qu'ils sont
les premiers sur la sellette il faut
imaginer que le l'idéologie djihadiste à
snj révolutionnaire déjà contre ces
états établis et corrompu tels que les
djihadistes les voies est contre l'ordre
religieux établi que ce soit en arabie
saoudite où par hasard ou par le roi
marocain il faut c'est ce qu'il faut
essayer d'imaginer ed imaginez quand
même donc ça fait partie des premiers à
cible des jihadistes les les monarchies
du golfe et c'est à d'ailleurs il
rappelle tout le temps que les avions
américains par du qatar et en arabie
saoudite ya des bases américaines le
premier conflit entre ben laden et
l'arabie saoudite ci a fait tout éclater
en fait c'est à la présence de soldats
américains sur le sol saoudien pour
combattre l'armée à 4 500 donc ça il
faut quand même se le rappeler ben laden
était déchu de sa nationalité etc alors
justement on s'est posé la question de
des pays les plus visés par ces
attentats parce terrorisme islamiste et
notamment la place de la france dans ce
fut le classement s'il jourdain vous
pouvez nous rejoindre sur quels chiffres
vous êtes vous appuyer pour nous donner
cette place de la france dans dans les
pays visés par le taraude les chiffres
de la fondapol la fondation pour
l'innovation politique les experts se
sont penchés sur les attentats
islamistes commis à travers le monde
entre l'année 1979 et mai 2021 pourquoi
79 et bien parce que ça correspond à un
basculement un tournant historique sur
la fondapol en 79 l'armée rouge envahi
l'afghanistan la même année on assiste
aussi à la révolution iranienne deux
événements qui ont contribué à
l'accélération et au développement du
terrorisme islamiste la fondation a donc
procédé à un recensement des attaques à
travers le monde elle en a dénombré plus
de 48 milles au total toujours entre 79
et 2021 sur cette période les attentats
ont fait plus de deux cent dix mille
morts c'est un peu plus de quatre morts
par attentats ça semble très précis
indiquent comme ça mais la fondapol le
reconnaît elle-même impossible
évidemment d'avoir un chiffre exact du
nombre d'attentats pour une raison qui
est assez simple c'est que beaucoup
d'attentats ne sont pas recensées par
les états eux mêmes oui alors concernant
la france quels sont les chiffres la
france est le 30e pays le plus touché au
monde par les attentats islamistes tout
en haut du classement on retrouve
l'afghanistan l'irak et la somalie plus
intéressante s'aperçoit que la france
est le pays européen le plus touché par
ces attaques entre 79 et 2021 80 deux
attentats ont frappé l'hexagone ça
représente 44% des attentats islamistes
en europe et 48% des victimes en europe
au total les attaques qui ont touché
l'hexagone ont fait 330 morts
quand on joue un peu thomas pour
regarder quelles sont les cibles des
islamistes on s'aperçoit que ce sont les
policiers qui sont visés en priorité
mais comment expliquer que la france
soit le
premier pays d'europe visé par les
islamistes il ya plusieurs raisons à ça
en selon toujours la fondapol en vrac on
peut mentionner l'engagement militaire
de la france à travers le monde on peut
aussi mentionner le passé colonial même
si évidemment il ya d'autres pays en
europe 1 qui ont été touchés par
l'islamisme et qui n'ont pas le même
passé colonial et enfin la présence
d'importantes communautés juive et
musulmane favorisant l' importation du
conflit
israélo palestinien en france voilà
quelques facteurs quelques facteurs
seulement qui permettent peut-être
d'expliquer son la fondapol pourquoi la
france est l'un des pays l'une des
cibles privilégiées du terrorisme merci
steve jour d'impôt pour ces chiffres ses
explications marc trévidic on
essaye comme ça par petites touches
d'évaluer la menace actuelle on est
plutôt dans un temps faible est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ce rapport à
2015 oui quand même obligés de voilà
mais j'ai connu aussi moi c'est de faux
plein si vous et une période de calme
entre 2006 et 2012 meyrin par exemple
mais faut se méfier parce que j'étais
juste sentir et je sais par exemple que
waziristan il y avait il y avait moi ce
gars elle a mis en contact avec la
belgique qui nous envoyer six personnes
des belges et des français pour faire
des attentats est le septième ça a été
mais ras et ça personne n'en parlait
c'est du travail des sages de
renseignements de la justice qui arriva
à démanteler des projets ils ont ils ont
pu d'oxygène puisqu'ils ont plus de
monde par rapport à moins de gens à
surveiller donc c'est pour ça que c'est
mieux qu'on respire aujourd'hui un peu
plus facilement c'est l inverse en 2015
exactement donc ils respirent plus mais
ça n'empêche que même dans cette période
de calme et bien à un moment donné paf
il se passe quelque chose qui n'est pas
quelque chose qui nous tombe comme ça
dessus il ya des signes précurseurs que
je ne connais pas parce que je ne suis
plus de l'anti terrorisme mais que je
voyais bien monté et ce qui fait que
j'ai toujours eu un petit recul quand
présente un évènement comme à loup
solitaire et c'est parce que bon on
voit bien
qu'ils nous avaient dû envoyer avant six
personnes pour faire les attentats mais
on en a pas ce que je veux dire ma
chambre était justement j'ai eu ni
instruction sur moi ce gars là où il si
ce combat que lui et malika el aroud sa
femme donc premier mari avait tué
massoud comme un poignet c'est quand
même pas celle d'un petit monde nous
avait envoyé donc je vois là donc ils se
passent peut-être des scandales et des
parts dans un terreau mais par exemple
après le
l'attentât au camion bélier a à nice le
14 juillet puis finalement bien un
procès a pris pas mal de gens mais c'est
ça la question c'est
parce que le plus souvent basses et ces
terroristes sont aussi là pour mourir on
a bien compris ça c'est rare d'avoir un
salaire et
donc qui on juge basse a dit fillon faut
faire ou pas faire des procès par défaut
mais dans une c'est pas étanche on a des
amis qui sont du droit commun qui vous
vendre une arme qui vont vous voir un
passeport pour prêter votre bagnole ils
savent même pas votre projet et puis
comme acquis sont parfaitement
conscients et qu'ils adhèrent au projet
il faut c'est ça une enquête faire le
tri là dedans il procès devra faire le
tri et il faut le faire pour mais elle
jette pour ça aussi qu'il faut entendre
les ressortissants français et belges
détenus en ch est d'ailleurs important
au negro personnes 1 en temps il y en a
même qui sont sous mandat d'arrêt
j'espère qu'ils sont partis qui sont
amenés en france du débriefing quand
même pas
utilisable dans une cour de justice on
avait vu les français de quang nam où le
débat qui avait été débranché avant
qu'on les ramasse
complet value seulement il ya combien de
français est ce que est ce que c'est
vous disiez zones grises elles sont est
ce qu'on sait précisément ou pas
entre entre libé l'est sait rien et à
des centaines de français moi j'en aurai
pas un chiffre des centaines de français
et surtout bêtes plus précis et surtout
je ne me permettrais pas parce que je
les ai pas à les suivre en plus il ya
des naissances il ya des gens qui
disparaissent et il ya des gens qui
restent et il ya des enfants qui rendit
donc on peut dire et c'est déjà assez
assez on va dire exceptionnelle et
prenant par rapport à toute la période
de l'histoire du tourisme en france
qu'aujourd'hui à des centaines de
français toujours en série et qu'ils
pourraient un jour devenir des dangers
potentiels ou pas d'ailleurs mais en
tout cas le problème n'est pas le
problème n'est pas que se donne pas les
moyens de l'évaluer nous dit d'une
certaine façon ou en tout cas il est
évalué mais pas de la bonne il n'y a pas
de décision on va dire qui va au delà de
l'avis de l'opinion publique ou une
décision étatique qui dit basta alors
que les américains la dernière moyenne
ya une semaine le stand commun
d'américains à rappeler encore une fois
les pays européens à reprendre leur sang
pour des raisons sécuritaires on parle
de l'armée américaine on parle pas de
droits de l'homme et de justice marc
trévidic il ya quelques années vous
alerter sur un disque je vous cite et de
lutte antiterroriste vous disiez noyer
perméable faillible et plus adapté à la
menace ça va quand ça va mieux
aujourd'hui avant 2015 n'avait pas les
moyens qui après
je vais vous dire que c'était la panique
à bord il faut être clair à partir du
moment où il ya des centaines et des
centaines de personnes à surveiller
c'est horrible il y en a qui partait en
série qui revenait qu'il déserte où on
sait même pas exister partie donc quand
c'était très très très difficile et on
était noyés objectivement donc mais
maintenant après 2015 a été témoin il ya
important la guerre aussi là bas ce qui
fait que la main la menace est fonction
de l'ennemi et des moyens qu'on met en
face ça évaluer une menace mais bon à la
y avait beaucoup de dehimi très
puissants qu'ils voulaient nous il des
moyens peu faible maintenant il ya des
moyens importants et halimi moins
puissants donc ça va mieux objectivement
même s'il peut se passer les attentats
mais ça va mieux la tergoule oui je
voudrais juste vous dire que lorsque
david thompson a écrit son bouquin soyez
djihadiste français ça a été un choc un
tel choc d'ailleurs que j'ai demandé une
commission denquête dans cette maison
qui a commencé à travailler six mois
avant charlie donc je veux dire c'était
sûrement c'est très très tard par
rapport à l'air mais ça veut dire
simplement que le législatif et
notamment au sénat on avait pris la
mesure de du danger et qu'après le
législateur est intervenu y compris avec
des moyens très importants et mme
bernard cazenave extérieur on a quand
même voté cinq ou six lois avec des
budgets extraordinaire un milliard entre
charlie et le bataclan pour réarmer les
services extra donc il ya eu quand même
des gros effort de fait qu'une prise de
conscience très importante et puis vous
avez probablement pour renouer avec le
sujet précédent vu le changement de
position en ce qui concerne les femmes
et les enfants qui étaient détenus en
syrie en irak et qu'on fait revenir donc
là aussi il faudra du débriefing sérieux
mais vous voyez bien que la doctrine a
changé le pendant l'été bon voila et
l'eau mais ça peut-être suivre oui mais
je reviens à votre livre l'abécédaire du
financement du terrorisme parce que il
ya des trous dans la raquette il ya des
ya des failles dans nos systèmes de
contrôle aujourd'hui et si oui
lesquelles alors d'abord il faut rendre
hommage à trac fincke et d'un service de
renseignements financiers qui travaille
très très bien avec des déclarations de
soupçon de plus en plus de deux
institutions ou d'acteurs ont besoin de
déclencher des déclarations de soupçon
ce qui permet d'améliorer les
dispositifs mais surtout y reste il faut
bien comprendre que les services et que
les terroristes utilisent les mêmes
circuits que la délinquance financière
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est blanchiment
fraude fiscale paradis fiscaux port
franc et que de ce point de vue là sur
la fraude fiscale sur les ports francs
sur les paradis fiscaux l'europe reste
encore un peu molle du genou si j'ose
dire est qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire sur le blanchiment ce
sont les mêmes réseaux est l'exemple le
plus symptomatique c'est par exemple la
contrefaçon vous achetez une chemise
avec un crocodile ou des chaussures de
sport extérieur d'ailleurs c'était un
des uns des criminels du bataclan qui
s'est financée avec des chaussures de
sport bon vous savez bien vous faites
pas une bonne action extrême vous avez
pas du tout le sentiment de financer des
réseaux terroristes et vinci est
majoritairement donc si vous voulez tout
ce qui est délinquance financière tout
ce qui est évidemment lié à cette
délinquance financière facilite le
financement du terrorisme est évidemment
de plus en plus créatifs donc il reste
effectivement des dispositifs à mettre
en place il faut que ce soit simplement
équilibré entre le intérêt général tous
les gens qui utilisent des cagnottes en
ligne on peut pas interdire les cadenas
temps l'insee très très pratique ça
parce que certains détournent et quelles
notes en ligne de leurs objets qu'il
faut les interdire il faut simplement un
peu mieux les surveiller est-ce que ça
fait partie du jeu je peux peut-être que
c'est pas du tout le monde terme et des
signaux faibles qui peuvent être
utilisés par un juge antiterroriste pour
pour anticiper une action les circuits
financiers ou est-ce que c'est déjà trop
tard avec d'abord il ya le macro
financiers microfinance est bien souvent
malgré tout on a eu affaire à des
groupes qui s'était auto financé par des
voies la mare mais par la contrefaçon
vêtements part du clonage de cartes
bancaires
aussi ces avc 500 michel aulas pour le
11 septembre 2001 1 le coup et après ses
vingt mille dollars pour djerba par
exemple bon donc ça le gers voilà il ya
le système d je parlais de deux jeunes
réunionnais qui étaient partis en syrie
en utilisant simplement une bourse
d'études comme il faut pas faire leurs
études à la réunion on a le droit dans
ce cas se faire payer l'avion et puis
5000 euros la première année pour aller
dans le cursus qu'on veut ans et ben
c'est ça leur permet d'aller en turquie
puis après d'aller en syrie l'argent il
y en a partout le crédit à la
consommation 10000 euros comme ça
l'argent pour les gens malhonnêtes il
n'ya qu'à se pencher là que ceux qui
sont honnêtes qui ont du mal à en gagner
si vous voulez un peu c'est un peu
facile de dire ça comme ça me cimon
l'argent en mono society et il y en a
voilà les résultats du court ça devient
très difficile parce que ça veut dire
que c'est global le financement et
théorise faut réfléchir non par contre
ça nous a permis de trouver des
complices dans les enquêtes quand vous
cherchez comment le groupe ses finances
et vous trouver des gens qui ont été
vous trouvez des complices en fait assez
facilement vous remontez comme en 95 les
attentats de paris bon à remonter à
rachid ramda a causé vermont western
union depuis londres ça nous est utile
plus pour ça pour empêcher une action
terroriste c'est compliqué c'est
tellement dur microfinance d'ailleurs
les américains ils ont prouvé le lien
entre l'état islamique central et sa
filiale au congo en vue de l'arrivée du
congo via un financer au kenya après
voilà donc c'est quelqu'un qui me
passait qui est passé l'argent du groupe
et qui touchait une petite prime à côté
et qui n'était pas du tout engagé
liturgiquement c'était juste pour des
raisons mercantiles
allez-y oui mais après évidemment on
fait qu'il ya eu des phénomènes de
financement massif on sait quand même
que l'état islamique il ya eu l'argent
de mossoul des banques mais il ya eu
aussi du trafic de pétrole s'étaient
rend le cs on le sait donc la couper le
financement sera conditions a consisté à
bombarder les cargaisons mais est ce
qu'il ya de nouvelles sources de
financement con con qu'on connaît qu'on
vient de découvrir ma terrible viens
découvrir je crois pas mais le fait de
les identifier une par une rend les
choses plutôt inquiétante parce qu'en
réalité ce sont des outils la vie
quotidienne ce sont les cagnottes en
ligne ce sont les cartes prépayées au
bond la tête de la microéconomie voilà
c'est la micro économie qui en fait est
détournée de son objet mais simplement à
partir du moment où on réfléchit en
termes de trafic d'armes évidemment
d'être humains piraterie qui est quand
même
dans le golfe de guinée mais pas
seulement ou en somalie ou ailleurs il
ya beaucoup de yann python
anecdotique le chocolat ou le miel mais
en réalité la créativité de ces
délinquants fait aussi que comme le
blanchiment reste encore possible à
cause de trous dans des dispositifs
évidemment utilisation de deux
plateformes opaque un peu les crypto
monnaie dont on dit que pas du tout
c'est très sûr à nos services sont pas
exactement d'accord avec ça
tout ce qui crée de l'opacité va
favoriser le financement du terrorisme
donc je pense qu'on a les uns et les
autres tous bien identifier l'ensemble
des sujets il reste maintenant à trouver
le bon moyen pour les surveiller c'est
quand même en gros progrès aussi et
heureusement après ça peut être des
choses très emballé inattendue par
exemple al qaïda ses finances et sur le
commerce de miel depuis l'afghanistan et
le pakistan pendant des années la l'état
islamique autour du lac tchad ils se
financent avec le commerce du poisson
voilà donc ses pets parfois des choses
très simples en irak l'état islamique
achètent des parkings et fait travailler
des gens dans des parkings alors qu'eux
mêmes ne savent pas qu'ils travaillent
pour l'état islamique et ses deux toutes
petites sommes accumulées qui font un
pactole qui permet de conduire une
action ci est encore une fois qu'ils
coûtent jamais très cher si les
financements les gueules aussi l'impact
du fils mme envisager une lancement les
bains vous travaillez vous faites une
activité économique pour tirer de
l'argent vous conservez vos familles
sahraouies vous étiez épargné
en même temps
voici non non je disais juste les
parkings les kiosques à journaux les
taxis oui mais là vous êtes en train de
nous décrire une multitude de
cécité mais c'est la vérité est ce que
je veux dire c'est que parfois de
l'argent qui est propre et qui devient
noire parce qu'il gagne en sécurité et
par foyer du blanchiment c'est de
l'argent qui est noir et qui devient
blanche donc c'est donc ces signaux
faibles les signaux faibles et plus
simple à détecter si je comprends bien
pour vous c'est quoi
même les sénatrices parler de traquenard
à la raison mais tracfin maintenant ils
vont pointer du doigt quelqu'un à cause
de son profil pas que pas que du
mouvement d'argent qu'il a généré c'est
parce que il a envoyé cet argent là mais
il est connu de la dgsi etc change de
l'information un mouvement qui est
normal cagnotte en ligne etc devient
inquiétant si c'est quelqu'un qu'on
connaît et cliquer voilà tout ça que
l'anc est l'information tout doit être
liés ce ne peut pas être ses trente
secondes pour terminer ses conclusions
tracks fin grâce à nos travaux des uns
et des autres et à vous à vos travaux
messieurs est aussi maintenant partie
intégrante de la communauté du
renseignement ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant ce qui évidemment favorise les
échanges de renseignements on en revient
toujours à la même chose c'est le
renseignement qui est le coeur du
dispositif contre le terrorisme merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci à tous les deux et merci
également à nathalie goulet frappé le
titre de votre livre l'abécédaire du
financement du terrorisme publié aux
éditions du cherche midi voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à toutes et
à tous de votre fidélité à public sénat
votre prochain rendez vous et que
l'élection c'est bonjour chez vous au
regard de mansigné reçoit jean françois
copé le maire lr les républicains 2 mo
belle soirée